- It's a really tense part of the world.
It's a complicated part of the world.
- Yes
- Israel, and all around.
- Yes.
So religion is
is at the core of that complexity.
One of the components
- Yes, it's a strong motivating cause
for many many people in
the Middle East, yes.
- In your view looking back,
is religion good for society?
- [Speaker] It's a good
question for robotics you know,
- [Interviewer] There's
echo's of that, for sure.
- It could be their religious beliefs.
Suppose we find out, or we agree,
that religion is good for
you to keep you in line
- [Interviewer] Ya,
- Should be given the metaphor of a God.
- The metaphor that the robot
would get us without it, also.
Robots will reason by metaphor.
And what is,
the most primitive metaphor?
A child growing.
Mother smiling, father teaching,
father image, and mother with God.
So, whether you want it or not,
- [Interviewer Chuckles]
- The robots will, assuming
that the robots are
going to have a mother and a father.
It may only have a program though,
that doesn't supply warmth and discipline.
- [Interviewer] Ya,
- Discipline with God.
The robots will have this
model of this trainer,
and everything that happens in the world,
cosmology and such,
is going to be mapped into a program.
With God.
- [Interviewer] Ya,
- [Speaker Chuckles]
- The thing that represents the origin of
everything for that robot.
- [Speaker] It's the most
primitive relationship.
- So it's going to
arrive there by metaphor.
And so the question is
if overall that metaphor
has served us well, as humans.
- I really don't know. I think it did.
But as long as you keep in mind,
it's only a metaphor.